from seven down in the final 20 6.8
seconds they went on to win in double
overtime at Barclays Center
20:31 125 Joe Harris simply one of the
best free-throw look back at the bench
spread his arms wide as if to say what
do you want me to do Irving
very awkward be the nineties to the two
times previously including almost a year
ago while back on October 24th last year
2010 against Minnesota
Irving pulls up and hits the terrain
fling the ball Christopher Irving all
the way to the bucket scored it and drew
the five free throws to start the game
early we talked about with Allen had
been the start of the first couple games
and look at the speed drill by Irving
going coast-to-coast this is this is one
on the Grizzly first he fakes the
dribble with the reverse spin then puts
it over the top both born in a paint
lightly pull up but swarm from the
free-throw line down the lane to this
beautiful feed almost the length of your
love your offers to play a nice cut the
timing on the cut and narrow one there's
one of those batted away from picked up
by Solomon Hill Moran again see he gets
to the left hand and it is over clamp
[Applause]
[Music]
that'll get your guy the basketball when
this year Maine for curbing the talent
banks it in and a foul on June second
foul on Jackson went to be both
facilitator has not been as aggressive
to score as he was in the first quarter
one team that's averaging better than 20
again
they have 12 already and there's a lot
for Jared Jackson that's a play with the
Grizzlies like to use early the second
half has been the issue for the
Grizzlies in each of the first two games
Moran figoratti mixed bag the first two
games but you I think you're seeing job
meeting the moment here going to Vega
Kyrie Irving's let's go to the rack flip
it up and Herbie got a piece of that
it's out of bounds there's not been a
number that's been placed on it turns
out by Perry or simply amazing that's
why he's a six-time all-star we saw a
Dillon Brooks explode for a 20 point
quarter in Oklahoma City when the
preseason
[Applause]
three point Brooklyn lead Miranda those
two guys have developed a pretty good
connection as with Brandon Clark sets a
heart roller and Durant always head up
jaws sixth assist of the game and
DeAndre Jordan
for working underneath trapped chairs of
the block in the neck away from behind
my no habla but the Grizzlies with
possession Koran to the cup Jennifer
screening roles as please watch moran
just take off partner and finish easily
on the interior so forced
DeAndre Jordan away from the basket bugs
hearing can also finish shots going to
the reverse Jaron can't stay on the
floor makes things very very difficult
my rant with 15 and 7 assists he was
going to get a score and right now
Brooklyn is the only team that has two
guys like that Moran 46 wagons wants a
screen to roll with Solomon Hill job to
the lead
Jones trying to give it back and
Dinwiddie with the steel trying to hit
Brandon Clark Brizzy turned it over
Laberge straight line drive drop B to
Irving
there's a big reason why they even got
something there Hank splashes enegry
Jersey's had a 15-point lead earlier
that's their largest 22:4 job
[Applause]
I ran on a baby
[Applause]
let's kick his the Friends of being so
special
the thing that special is how far he's
able to take off to be able to finish I
mean again he takes off one step inside
the free-throw line
Moran picked up by den way ten seconds
job down the lane off the collects it in
seven of the last ten points for the
home team and he's tied the game at 120
shot blocker who
against Moran
[Applause]
one of the best players on the planet
against a rookie and a rookie meets the
moment he doesn t see stays down doesn't
jump put a head fake and then is able to
use his size and length to come up with
a huge block on Carver every almost
forgot though it could have got the ball
who called the timeout Parrish Laberge
Erving Allen and Dinwiddie boy Jaron
came very close to a sixth class
[Music]
for being with 33 Marant with 30 they go
pick-and-roll at Irving flips it up at
an
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content